[Music]
no Spalding Amish undeveloped valuable
Carly said now you men a glutton hey
girlies are ten boxes whole we shake it
up
sidenote no bread makers were injured in
the making of this video as you can
probably gather this is not your average
bread maker nor is this your average
bread oven nor isn't your average bread
this is shot Esprit and in Georgian that
translates to well bread a certain task
faced area had same tone it equals are
equal to each other
Akil embraced an eighth highest angle
trot second Hudson true
canary heart poori at him impact of
swelling only sarcana on sort of Tagore
Telenet carve carve ovince our K Mitra
visited since I make me an opportunity
me don't you stop she starts on a toner
oven is essential to the making of
shortest period after the oven is built
and the heat is turned up to the highest
level for six to seven hours the walls
of the oven are covered in a salt based
liquid and diving in to get the bread as
close to the fire is just a part of the
job
hot stove me no option kitchen cotton
Paulo hit the s10 scores all think about
home as if diving into a clay pot is an
intense enough this thing hits
temperatures of 750 to 900 degrees
Fahrenheit the end result is a special
bread with a salty twist that's eaten on
special occasions like birthdays
weddings Christmas and New Year's it's
hot stratum serum it's hot it's alma
mater Chicago River watch me
[Music]
most cathedrals have been built to
withstand the test of time but not this
one
welcome to the easter arches of Sicily
Italy but come quick
they weren't lost
[Music]
every Easter the town of San viaggio in
Sicily Italy is home to a Cathedral made
out of breads cereals and pastas
visitors are able to wander through the
arches of bread and enjoy the detailed
designs up close the structure is
created by locals and takes around three
months to construct the origins of this
tradition date back to ancient times
when visiting Royals expected to be
greeted with grand displays San viaggio
was a town of mercy poor farmers so they
used what they had bred in the mid 18th
century the tradition became a
celebration of Easter
although the appetizing displays aren't
edible a walk through the arches of
bread is a testament to the city's long
history and the artistic capabilities of
its citizens
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
baguettes in Paris are like fish in
water
birds in the sky tourists at note
Radames they just belong and there is
one man who makes the fluffiest
crispiest baguettes in all of Paris he
is a master of the most French food
there is and he happens to be the son of
a Tunisian immigrant acidification have
an excellent laptop Orchestra bombay
question blank ribbon show concert a
telephone a donkey and a village
illegally deposited ago spill official
lose and go party create a media image
say magic Connecticut for Marco Castillo
see shaken a young composer Delamere
tradition by some co-ed official Pascal
silicon coup Chiara please donate $1
mongolab
their focus on panchkula made-up report
on sale about yet asked us to mollify
guess is Cuba's ensemble voces de
Janiero Concord lmf traditionally do me
digit Matt no look Papa because it no
more to the point a fashion show for my
stamp is a another way to limit our
personal mom was crippled machine Shetty
I'm at non-federal favor say on quietly
no parent is e ontology another move
Japan was kai-shek blood on the rigid
motion Japan preview long as a negative
i neva neva para la Piedad upon the
pitot booty we recorded on the library
the provocative a dream Allah's evaded
rhythm discipline see Asian get a new TV
just a meaty fatty go on select all
finita Gigante acutally APA Jeter party
in my tummy Sebastian yuan Fang he needs
to control her own gossipy subtours repo
Navajo as capable as affect Caracas
anonymity look keep on watching Walken
is also level
the scheme wobbly the trustees want
Julie Google has a meaty fatty goes on
fabric exactly to see if I should have
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
the Queen Amon is a specialty of
northern France derived from the Briton
words for butter and cake the ratio for
this pastry is special it's buttery in
fact it's 30 percent butter and 30
percent sugar
[Music]
welcome to dois Rene a city with a
population of around 15,000 this small
coastal town has a few main attractions
including touring the coastlines
visiting the port museum and seeing the
Chapelle of san michele but that's not
why we're here
we are here to meet Terry Luca the man
to talk to when you want a truly
authentic Queen Amman pastry cream on a
Tarantino domine Sanka - empty - was a
legend goes a baker ran out of goods in
their shop and had to whip up something
quickly consider a party see I'm worried
cos kill every trauma either Phillip at
a time in a pretty bird in a pretty sure
we don't hear it wasn't video a they
were commended the pastry has only a few
simple ingredients but don't let that
fool you
shouldn't participate as c.difficile
affair what did you get a free Amman to
donate it to the fair amount of Nutella
but Omega by Omega six seconds on the
develop a villa Pat should do - whenever
you are a kid you have if you remain
liquid in a street or assembly quite
often put individually I want the metro
[ __ ] you I give a favor will ya carry me
to the storage issue
the happiest had appear one was a very
large to sit we talk to friends because
mentality Boulanger awawa
is a second cat home at not a failure
but I said come on to talk we don't
think it's definitely a treat probably
not something you'd eat every day and to
fail to live here to go miss if I do to
tone is a bit wobbly or I'd only on
afraid and like a dealer that was a
traditional so I got to push a physio or
ah-ha that's all - ski suit cause I
don't you in the ocean please Ayodhya
not to have the last word but obviously
we tried it we're not by Tina and I
think our face says it all and also this
spontaneous remark oh my god that's so
buttery
you owe me ten out of ten would
recommend
I sort of fell in love with the country
with the people with the with the idea
of the revival of a Jewish community in
the country of Ukraine and I decided
that this is where I want to be I want
to stay here and open a bakery my name
is Aaron Lovitz I'm a baker from New
York living in it was good on Ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
I met my my wife when I was in culinary
school in New York countries from
Ukraine so we decided to move to Ukraine
I can't really sit in New York where
everything is Jewishly comfortable when
I know that in Ukraine things are
difficult I feel that I have a larger
connection with the Jews of Ukraine
Jewish life in neutral before the work
compared to today is a huge contrast
before the war you had many synagogues
many rabbis the Nazis came and they
shipped everyone out to Auschwitz and
now there's no real community my part
now in the Jewish community is to it
make an attempt at a Jewish revival and
so we're starting with food it's not
really practical to make a kosher bakery
in Ukraine or knows your dog just for
Jews you're not really gonna make any
money because it's not enough Jews so
that's why I want to introduce new ideas
new American pastries Jewish pastries
that are just not common here so try to
get the interests of people
I would say that I'm introducing some
Jewish and American foods that are non
judgmental some people are scared to go
to a synagogue or scared to go to a
prayer service or something but they'll
come in to a bakery and have something
tasty
[Music]